you guys are pretty girls what made you
guys go to the fans route and not the
gold digger
I just feels like if I was in that
situation I feel like I would go the
gold digger out you know like sugar
daddy I'm not sugar daddy I I'd be like
okay this is what I was thinking I went
to box seats the other day Okay my dad
his friend had box seats we went to like
this is very like these you know what
box seats are yeah it's very expensive
they're all rich right and I was
thinking there's a girl that was doing
the cart for the desserts this girl was
so heavy right she was so fat and I was
just like that is a waste of an
opportunity
and he was telling me like sometimes
people just like want to tell you
stories on one-on-one set I don't know
it was interesting but he was telling me
he's like girls going through the wrong
Rich guys to go after the managers when
the owners are the ones like they're
average guys at these places no girls
really talk to him and he's like they're
worth like 60 70 million I'm like if I
had to choose I gotta just go that route
[Music]
you're in the same room as all the guys
worth 60 million yeah it's not like
that's that hard of a job to get Barker
girl how are you going to get the 20 000
in 30 days
[Music]
I think
where I was at because of uh emotionally
like my trauma and all of that I
actually looked older and I I think I'm
like more in my Prime now than when I
was younger like I looked tired and worn
out and beat down like you could see
that like the world was wearing on me
and I don't think like the energy that I
was putting out was conducive for me
finding like someone like that I wasn't
until now that I'm like okay like I can
dress like a lady I like know how to
hold myself and have like those
conversations because it only has
allowed me to have that time to myself
um and now I'm in those rooms where I'm
starting to like meet those men and talk
to that but when I had no money I didn't
have any money to buy nice clothes to
like buy a nice dress and and have the
time off all right you can't give up 20
000 a month yeah so I actually I went on
a date with like I don't know you could
turn him as a sugar daddy I met him at
like a rich bar in Boston like in Back
Bay and he's like I want to take you out
and I was like okay like this guy's in a
nice area like why not try the sugar
daddy route that's when it was really
being pushed on social media I feel like
he was probably 40 but I was also 19. so
like I was like oh he's so old like he
must have so much money and then we went
on a date he took me to a shitty
restaurant I was like oh this dude's got
no money his Volvo had to busted out
headlight I was like oh man I cannot
choose them or sugar daddy ever I cannot
choose them but how did you determine
that he was a sugar daddy just as he was
40. were you on a site I didn't know I
just guessed I was like oh he probably
has money like you know he was in like
the financial district I go there he's
like yeah I want to have no
I'll give you a hundred bucks and I was
like
and that completely turned me off to
Sugar dating I was like no thank you I'm
so good I I really value like connection
like I really want to like feel
connected so like the money can't be the
only thing a hundred dollars for Ross
you got me so what was the number
okay what was the right number then for
real sex
what was the right number 200.
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh I'm just kidding
she's getting 2 000.
the right number now after I think only
fans did make me feel more secure in
myself and I feel a lot more confident
now I swear if you saw the change in
like my photos and videos and how I
carried myself and not like even the
only fan stuff I'm not gonna I would say
the world that only is able to provide
yeah but like just like regular I would
post on social media I feel a lot more
confident and I don't know where I was
going with this you just been able to
actually actually okay wait I don't
think obviously taking that time to grow
though it's our question did you know
before you started like people might
look at you a certain way yes yeah okay
yeah that was I think a lot of people in
the month you're like so I was so when I
started it I was like okay the pandemic
is gonna be the day I had like broken up
with the boyfriend and moved in with
Emily that day pandemic started like the
lockdown and that's when when like the
finance stuff was happening and I ended
up getting like discriminated against
um in my company by like my new sales
manager and some one of my ex-best
friends got mad I was making more money
than her in sales and went to my boss
and was like she has
and so I went through like basically a
legal battle with my company for a
couple months and I was like this isn't
Gonna Last the job Market's gonna be
hard my friend who had like no so she's
like I made 700 like why don't you just
try it you don't have to do anything and
I was like you know what like I won't
show any like show that much
no during this time and so I was just
when I was deciding to start it and I
was looking at it I was like okay I'll
do it for three months I'll become like
the comedian ones who does like topless
comedy I'll get the marketing out of
that I'll get a boost in my income and
I'll take that time to look for another
job and like be in Corporate America but
something like deep down was like you
don't want to be in Corporate America
well yeah the money that you made said
that you didn't want to be in Corporate
America I was also getting like 17 000
commission checks from being in sales so
like you have to hump it though yeah it
was it was so stressful and so I was
like wow I'm doing a court like a
fraction of the work and I'm making
money and once I started making like
good money I was like oh
I took that as like you have to dive in
because I sold marketing but see I know
y'all can't ever talk to a regular guy
again all right
I think there's a lot of regular guys
who are okay do I think like the ones
that are yours I want a regular guy
but see she being uh she sees me unreal
you can't talk you can't talk to a
regular guy I don't know right but what
woman wants a regular guy what is a
regular guy you know like how God makes
I gotta make sixty thousand dollars a
year once kids you know 401K you don't
want that guy no I don't think I ever
wanted a guy who is only making sixty
thousand dollars a year what's that
what's the minimum threshold
I don't know because for me it depends a
lot on personality oh no maybe when you
start I think
so when he says the number you're like
oh well this personality that's true the
guy making 60 also had a personality
yeah right all right you got me right so
those guys are the good ones but if
we're okay we're in media and are like
we're doing that we're you already need
like a certain type of man that's gonna
handle it with you being online and all
the time only fans aside so if you're a
social media what do we need to make
that they just need to be an
entrepreneur have a good job that's not
what she said okay so what's my dollar
limit you're saying because I just hit
the floor I mean everything anybody like
30 million yeah but what's the floor I'd
say like 120 120 around there
what about you
I would say I would want when my dad was
doing well he was making like a decent
amount and that really did help our
family and based on like my biggest
drama is like the financial stuff if
you're making 60k a year I already know
if we have say we have three kids you're
making 60k a year I'm not doing only
fans so I'm working under you you can't
one you can't pay me to work under you
that's not enough for me to take away
from having another job and then there
there's not a lot of disposable income
there if something happened we're in a
recession whatever happens saving up for
college like 60k is not a lot in terms
what's the minimum
I would say like 150
so you won 20 you won 50. yeah so you
want 150 but also you want a guy that is
going to accept your only fans pass I
think with 150 if you're an entrepreneur
you're already a little bit more open to
different ways of life even if you're in
corporate or Finance or you're a surgeon
no they are not I will tell you no no no
I grew up in a family of entrepreneurs
they would none of them all my brothers
make six figures none of them will take
home I feel like guys who are in more
like boxed in jobs
yeah but I mean it just depends I guess
like what they're saying what's on fans
if if they've got content like I'm a
YouTuber right so if I make
and I've got some private YouTube videos
that YouTube doesn't want me to
uploading because they're gonna
demonetize it right so I put in only
fans that's one thing but you know I
started unbuttoning my pants
hold up so no I mean there's just so
many other women out there right that's
the only thing
um for sure there are women that you
know and I'm not saying there's anything
wrong right because if you're getting 20
grand a month it's like hey man yeah you
know but that's also okay that that's
your boundary that you wouldn't want to
date a woman who has shows
that have husbands right you know what
I'm saying so I mean you and I we talked
to uh
you and I talked to a YouTuber and like
he was like you know damn his marriage
right yeah that was wild yeah so you
know I want to be in on the secret
[Music]
you know if if and they're happy right
so like more power to them right but to
to to regular guys like you know me and
Anton you know we really can't imagine
our wife going to her boyfriend's house
and then
she my wife is giving her boyfriend head
and then coming home and kissing me yeah
that's my wife oh wow no yeah unless
you're doing it together like I wouldn't
know even then like together or apart
there's no no one's coming in my wife's
mouth
all of this together no no no no no no
no
it's gonna work
we're not watching it I'm traumatized
we learn a lot I have a lot of men as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible